and I think you can be concerned that
there's not enough mobility or enough
opportunity but you don't have to also
believe that things are getting worse hi
I'm Nicolas be with Reason TV and today
we're talking with Scott Winship he is a
PhD fellow at the Brookings Institution
in Washington DC Scott thanks for
talking to us oh my pleasure things so
you do a lot of work on kind of related
concepts of income inequality and income
mobility everybody seems to be
interested in any income inequality the
gap between the wealthiest and the
poorest people also talk a lot about
income ability the ability of a person
to move from kind of one end of income
spectrum to the other and everybody
whatever their you know whatever their
ideology is seems to agree income
inequality has spread more and that
income mobility is over you have people
like charles murray and coming apart
thing it's over timothy noah in his
recent book about income mobility saying
it's over
you take issue with that statement talk
a little bit about what your work on
income ability is found peoples kind of
talk researchers journalists talk
offhandedly about the American Dream
declining the mobility has declined the
research is much more ambiguous than
that it's not clear at all that mobility
has declined and in part I think people
are wedded to this idea that it has
declined because there is a consensus as
you say that inequality has increased
and so people talk about the rungs of
the income ladder growing further apart
and it's so I mean they're basically
saying okay because the richest 1% or
the richest 10% is much richer than the
lowest 10% then mobility between these
sections have to become it has to be
harder that's right
where inequality is really taking off is
at the very top of the ladder and so if
you're using this ladder metaphor you
know what's happened is the top rung has
has flown away from everybody else but
there's no reason that that makes it any
more difficult to climb you know the
bottom two-thirds of the ladder for
instance so from your research basically
what you're finding is that it's it's
not that everybody has
an equal shot at becoming a
bazillionaire or anything but that the
rates of mobility in 1970 are roughly
the same as they are now that's right
and I think you can be concerned that
there's not enough mobility or enough
opportunity but you don't have to also
believe that things are getting worse
right but and yet when you've got it to
print in a variety of places you've
talked about this at everywhere from
national review to the Atlantic to your
own work at Brookings and whatnot you
routinely get attacked for you know why
are people so mad if you're actually
bringing some good news I think there's
an analogy on the right where if you're
a cultural conservative for instance
that you know the gay uncle and your
family in some sense is this existential
you know threat to your to your
worldview and it becomes I think you
have a similar situation on the left or
if you start to acknowledge that some
things actually are not getting worse or
getting better it it starts to chip away
at the whole bundle of commitments is
there an easy way to say let's say you
you were born right at the poverty line
what are what are your odds of becoming
fully middle class or upper middle class
or rich so if you're born in the bottom
fifth you have about a 40 percent chance
that you're actually going to stay there
when you're an adult as well now people
look at that and think oh that's that's
great you know 60 percent make it out
and other people look at it and say well
this is a travesty the way that I tend
to put it in context is if you start in
the bottom what are the chances that you
end up in the top to fifth so kind of
the solid middle class upper middle
class it turns out you have about a 17
percent chance of doing this but how do
we jack up the 17% chance that a
low-income person has to get up to the
top forty percent of income there is a
small revolution I think that's starting
to happen with randomized controlled
trials and and really trying to figure
out what works and to try to pursue
those policies and to abandon ones that
don't including some relatively popular
ones things like head start that
actually don't look like they they have
much longer term impact and that's an
early intervention preschool program and
early early elementary school program
that's right the primary way that the
federal government
nests in import kids before school how
did you get interested in questions of
income ability since being in college
I've been in urban places and have
noticed the inequality and have had
spent a lot of time really thinking
about the disadvantages of growing up in
concentrated poverty in poor
neighborhoods and and and that's really
what originally got me interested in it
as well and and then as I found out over
time you know a lot of the economic
trends that I think liberals tend to
overstate how how bad things are getting
to the extent that some of those
actually don't look all that bad at all
I think what is left of the problems
that are kind of worth worrying about to
me a limited opportunity people who
start in the bottom kind of rises to the
top by default I guess well Scott
Winship of the Brookings Institution
thank you so much for talking to Reason
TV today about income mobility I'm Nick
Gillespie for Reason TV